[Music]
hello everyone
in all the previous lectures of 3d
elasticity we have stated that whatever
we were discussing it was finally to
build up to a situation
where we'd be able to solve the kelvins
problem so finally we are here
uh so i had briefly discussed
uh the statement of the kelvins problem
earlier uh let me do that in a slightly
greater detail now so we consider an uh
an infinite body so i i represent
the boundary of that body in this
fashion
uh it doesn't mean of course that this
body is just limited
to this boundary okay so you understand
that this boundary
uh it is just to mean that we do have
some material
here but this boundary is just i mean
way into
i mean way off into infinity okay
what we also say is that so earlier i
had mentioned that
we had a point body force
acting on this body
now what i uh as a
as a as a slight generalization to that
what i will do here
is to not consider a body like this
rather not consider a body force like
this
rather
what i'll do is i'll consider
a body force which is
which is perhaps like this
okay acting at certain point
and i will consider
a reference axis
in this fashion
[Music]
so let's say this is
x1 x2
and x3 and what we say is that
the position vector of the point where
uh this point body force is
acting this blue colored arrow is acting
this point
here
so the position vector of that point
what we say is
this is z vector okay so now it has been
set up in a general fashion
so going forward what we'll do is we'll
try to address
this general form of the kelvins problem
using the papkovitch neural
representation
and whatever we had discussed in our
previous lecture
in relation with the solution of the
poisons equation
and the direct delta function
and then we will consider
a more specific version of this kelvins
problem
where we considered this body again
when we consider this body again
but now we think
of uh so so maybe we
we
let me see if i can rotate this thing
okay
so what i would what i'm saying is
suppose i look at it in a
slightly rotated fashion such that
this blue colored arrow it is now
vertical
[Music]
so it's not an exact diagram but you you
understand what i'm
doing here okay so it's the exact same
situation here physically i'm just
looking at it in a third
in a slightly rotated fashion next what
i will do is
that instead of this kind of a general
coordinate system
x1 x2 x3 i will
[Music]
note or observe something special going
on here
you note that this boundary here is
completely arbitrary okay
arbitrary in the sense that i have just
drawn it for the sake of visualization
but this boundary is not really here
this is way off into infinity
okay so uh what i what you
what you must appreciate here is that
there is
a certain uh cylindrical
symmetry going on here so what i mean by
that is that
uh suppose you were to construct
a cylinder around
this uh this point body force
represented by this arrow and uh
suppose you construct is a cylinder like
this
[Music]
okay whose longitudinal axis coincides
with with the with this arrow
okay so no matter where you are sitting
on the surface of this circular cylinder
the situation is going to look exactly
the same
so what we mean to say is that there
there is no dependence
on on the on the angle of
i mean suppose you considered this
particular
line so if suppose if i had to draw a
line here ah
this horizontal line uh suppose we say
that
looking from the top that this is this
is uh
and you consider another line here maybe
so suppose this angle is theta
okay so there is no difference between
this line and this line
or you you consider any other line any
other radial line like this
all around it it doesn't make any
difference okay so all of these
radial directions they're exactly the
same so
let me clear up this drawing
now because of this kind of a nice
cylindrical symmetry about it what we
can do is we can consider
a cylindrical coordinate system which is
a much more specific thing to talk about
going from this x1 x2 x3 system so we'll
consider a cylindrical coordinate system
where this direction
is r
[Music]
this direction is z
and since there is no dependence on the
theta we don't have to talk about it
now uh this kind of a
r z plane you can construct it at any
theta
so so as as i had drawn earlier
so you consider any theta angle you can
have a r z plane there
uh now what i'm basically saying is that
no matter which r z plane you consider
it's going to be the same okay because
there is because of this
nice cylindrical symmetry or axis
symmetry
around this around this longitudinal
axis
all right now the immediate question is
uh some students may be thinking that
uh all right so effectively what we are
doing here
is is it not saying that we are reducing
this 3d elasticity problem to a 2d
elasticity problem
the answer is a strict no we are not
doing that
okay although it may seem like that we
are not really reducing this 3d
elasticity problem to a 2d elasticity
problem
just because we are talking about the
only the rz plane
it does not mean that and you will see
uh that
when you finally find out the various
stress components
okay so um it will be
it can be absolutely clear that this is
not really a 2d elasticism this is very
much 3d elasticity
all right so without talking anymore uh
let me actually
get on with the the steps of the kelvins
problem so
so just to reiterate before proceeding
any further uh
or before starting is that we are going
to start with this general thing then we
are going to specialize to this thing
and then uh find our solution forms all
right
so uh let me go to the next page here
uh
[Music]
so solution
[Music]
of the kelvins problem
[Music]
using the papkovic number representation
[Music]
so uh to reiterate uh
what we had in the pabkovic novel
representation was
uh we were dealing with uh
two uh two things so one of them was
this b vector and we said that the
solution
of the 3d elasticity problem it could be
reduced to the solution
of two sets of positive equations
so one of them was in this fashion
so del square b vector is equal to
[Music]
rho b vector divided by
2 into 1 minus nu
and del square beta
which was a scalar that beta was
that del square beta was equal to minus
expected dotted with
rho b vector divided by
2 into 1 minus nu
this robbie vector here uh these
uh this is the body force so this is the
general representation of the body force
uh
as we have been seeing from our stress
uh on our chapter on stress
uh but now what we are going to say is
that
uh this body force
uh must be made specific to the problem
at hand
so the problem at hand is this kelvins
problem
here the point where this thing is
acting this body forces this point body
force is acting
up is this psi vector
and since this is a point vector
since it's a point body force what we
can do is
and let's say that the the magnitude of
uh or the or the the force vector
representation of this is
uh like p vector
okay so that's uh
[Music]
so so in this equation what we are going
to say is
uh that this rho b vector it gets
substituted
by this p vector but it is not enough to
write it like a p vector
because that would imply that this p
vector is of
is acting at any general point within
the body so no matter which
x vector you choose within the body this
p vector
would apply but that is not the case
that p vector is applying
is being applied only and only at the
position
x vector is equal to psi vector
and how do we specify that using the
direct delta function 3d direct delta
so if you write it like this
then it means that according to the
definition of the direct delta if you
refer back to
the previous lecture it means that
whenever
our psi ours or this x vector is not
equal to the psi vector then this entire
result is equal to zero which is what
exactly what you want
so uh and and wherever this x is equal
to
uh the psi vector you have that that
that concentrated body force acting okay
so so this is how
we we convert the general statement
of this population representation to
uh something specific to our problem in
a similar fashion for this second
equation also
we write it like so we replace this rho
b vector by this
p vector with the direct delta
[Music]
so identifying this particular thing
okay so this is this is the most
important preliminary step
okay now all this hard work that we have
been doing
uh in discussing uh the mathematical
precursors uh the various
representations and all these things
it is it has been leading up to this
point okay so what i'm going
what i'm going to write next is directly
the solution that we are going to
need okay so
[Music]
you note that uh both of these
so del square b vector is equal to this
entire thing it may look complicated
but ultimately this del square b vector
is equal to this thing
it basically means that this is a
poisson's equation this del square beta
is equal to this thing
it's complicated looking but it is after
all a poisonous equation
so if it is a poisonous equation uh we
should definitely be able to write
down the particular solutions to both
these equations
this del squared beta uh b vector and
the del square b
beta using the forms that we had
discussed in the previous lecture
okay so what we say is that the
particular solutions
[Music]
to these poisons equations
are in this form so
for the first equation the particular
solution
is uh so you know that we need a
minus 1 by 4 pi let's write that
minus 1 by 4 pi and then
within the integration we'll have
this this entire thing
[Music]
p vector delta
[Music]
so i have simply written the right hand
side of this equation so this is like
the small f vector which was present
in the general form of the pollen's
equation and then
i need to write this
x vector minus so
so i have to be a little bit careful
here that this
x vector this is replaced by the x
dash vector and what i have in the
denominator is this
x vector minus the x dash vector
just like we had done in the case of the
example problem
at the end of the previous lecture and
this
integration is with respect to the x
dash vector
the cube represents that we are
integrating over the entire volume of
concern
of course is an infinite volume but no
matter we can
we can proceed in exactly the same
fashion
so uh what is the what is the
result of this so you understand that
here this p
vector it is a vector but it's a
constant so
exactly like the example problem that we
had done
in the previous uh lecture so this can
be taken out of the integration so also
this 2 into 1 minus nu can be taken out
of this
integration and ah what will be left
within the integration is this delta uh
x vector dash minus psi vector uh
divided by this magnitude and uh so let
me
let me write that down
[Music]
so this is 8 pi
1 minus nu and i have
within my integration
direct delta x dash minus psi
vector divided by
this thing
[Music]
so the result of this okay so all that i
have to do
in order to actually carry out this
integration uh
is to uh utilize the filtering property
of this direct delta
here and we have already done this in
the example problem so it's exactly
like that so the result of this is
simply
this remains as it is from the previous
step
and what we have here is simply the
x vector minus this x vector dash this
gets replaced by this
specific point where the point body
force is acting
[Music]
that's it okay so you see this
particular solution for the b vector
which is very much a part of the pabco
vision orbit representation
that is a function of x vector and here
we have the
dependence on the x vector through the
presence of this term here
and note that this psi vector is just
something specific which has been given
to us as part of the problem statement
meaning that this is the that is this is
it is the
the point where the body force is being
acting so in exactly the same fashion
we can proceed with this second equation
the the particular solution to that
is is given by again we write the same
thing
[Music]
we faithfully follow the method which
has been developed
[Music]
and let the dresser take care of itself
[Music]
so again uh you you understand now
that uh here i have to make a little bit
of a correction
in the sense that in the numerator
whatever was
an x here that has to be made an x dash
and this also has to be made in x dash
so now the thing that i can actually
take out
from here is this p but there is a
little bit of a complication
in the sense that there is a dot here
but we don't have to worry about it
you can understand that the result of
this
will be obtained by substituting
in whatever the function is as
present as a coefficient of this dirac
delta
in that function wherever the x dash is
present we just have to replace it by
the psi
okay so let me do that so at one shot
uh i can write my answer so uh
please note that there is uh another
slight mistake
so there is already a minus here so uh
this minus
is coming from the the the general form
of the solution of the of the person's
equation
so there is actually a minus here also
so overall there is a plus here
and what we are obtaining is
this uh so again there's a 8
pi 1 minus nu
and in the numerator i don't have to
write this one
[Music]
rather i'll just substitute this x dash
vector by the psi
psi vector that is dotted with the p
vector
[Music]
and in the denominator i have just like
before
the x vector minus the psi vector
that's it this is the solution
the this is my particular solution for
the beta
okay
now that we have in our hand the
particular solutions for this
b vector and the beta uh you would be
naturally thinking that
okay in order to complete the solution i
have to find out
the homogeneous part but actually it
turns out that we don't have to do that
okay so i'm not going to go into formal
proof of that
but at the end i will discuss
why this is so so for now i will
leave uh i'll leave out a
a missing link from here okay so
i'm deliberately leaving a missing link
here so
the missing link is this
[Music]
that how the particular solution
which we have just written how the
particular solution
[Music]
becomes the total solution
[Music]
[Music]
okay so we'll come back to a little
discussion of it
at the end it will not be possible for
me to go into a formal proof of it
but i i hope as engineering students you
will appreciate the hand-waving kind of
argument that i will present to you all
right so
uh so with this uh with this missing
link still uh nagging at us we'll
proceed
uh so what we'll say is that using this
these two particular solutions only we
are going to construct our
uh our displacement vector okay because
you see
these these help us uh so these are part
of the population over representation
but these themselves are certainly not
the
displacement vector so what is the
displacement vector so let me go back
to that representation
from uh from a couple of lectures back
and just write down uh the the the
expression
for the displacement vector in terms of
this b
vector and the beta vector appreciating
again that i am actually
writing the uh i mean util i'm going to
utilize only the particular solution
parts okay
these of course will turn out to be the
complete solutions but more of that
later
so this is u vector is equal to one by
twice g
uh gradient
of the the uh
sorry that's the beta vector so this is
just the beta plus
dot product of x and
b minus
4 into 1 minus nu b
vector
okay
now uh going forward it will be easier
if i just write this one by two g i mean
if i just
multiply this thing here okay so i don't
have to keep on writing this
twice c in this denominator over and
over again
so it's just a convenience
sorry i made the mistake again so this
should be just
beta plus x dot
p minus 4 into
1 minus mu b vector
[Music]
all right so what i'll do is i'll just
substitute this
beta p and the pp here
[Music]
okay so this is
gradient uh
[Music]
directly utilizing what i have present
here so this is
i dotted with p
[Music]
divided by pi 1 minus
nu expected
minus psi vector
[Music]
and i have
next up
[Music]
the x dotted with b so this is my b
so all that i have to do is just
[Music]
so this my plus becomes a minus
[Music]
[Music]
all right so let me just check it once
more
if i'm writing it correctly so if you
just compare it here
all that i have done here is just
dotting this thing
in this numerator with the x dot because
i have this x dot b
okay so this entire thing is within
bracket because the gradient is
operating on this entire thing
and i also have
[Music]
this 4
into 1 minus nu and there is this b
vector which is this so there is a plus
here
then p vector divided by 8 y pi
1 minus nu expected
minus z vector
[Music]
okay so this 1 minus nu cancels with
this 1 minus nu
so overall what i'm getting is
uh see there is
a a little bit of a simplification that
can be carried out here
so i can actually write it
as x minus psi x vector minus i vector
dotted with p so i'll take this minus
sign
out of this gradient and write it in a
slightly
more compact form
[Music]
in this way
so you can already see that uh
things are shaping up quite compactly
here
okay let us not forget that this
gradient is operating on the whole thing
and for the second term we have
p vector divided by twice pi
x vector minus the psi vector
okay now remember what we said earlier
we had said that for the solution
of the kelvins problem we are first
going to start
from this general uh kind of a situation
where we do not uh where we keep this
coordinate axis
general this x1 x2 x3 that is exactly
what we have done
by
by by writing our entire thing
in terms of this general x vector
and considering that the point body
force is acting
at this at this point psi
uh with this position vector psi now as
discussed earlier we are going to make
it uh
we are going to change our viewpoint to
this
particular situation where we take a
very specific choice
of this x 1 x 2 x 3 coordinate system in
the form of a cylindrical coordinate
system
and as a further specialization what we
do
is we choose the origin
of we choose the origin of our
coordinate axis
as you can see here this coordinate axis
uh the the the origin of this coordinate
axis
is coinciding with this point of
application of the body force
the immediate implication is here is
that
what was i here
in this diagram what was i here so
here that z becomes zero
okay because the point of application of
this body force
with respect to this cylindrical
coordinate system is nothing but the
origin itself
so psi vector is nothing but the zero
vector itself the origin vector
okay so if we specialize to such a uh
such a diagram
then our entire formulation will become
much
simpler okay so furthermore what we'll
also note is that
what what happens to this form of this
magnitude of this
x vector okay so let me go to the new
page
and discuss all these details so
now we
now we
change uh our our viewpoint
to uh let's call this
figure one and figure two okay
so let's say this is figure 1
and this is figure 2
please note and be very careful that
as far as the actual physical situation
is concerned because you see this
coordinate acts as the choice of the
coordinate axis
how you are representing all of this is
this is just a mathematical choice
but the actual physics it remains the
same so whatever was the situation here
is exactly the same physical situation
here okay
so uh
so we are very much still solving the
kelvins problem we just
are making a nice more convenient choice
uh
of our viewpoint so we change our
viewpoint to figure 2
[Music]
okay so where
[Music]
our psi vector is equal to 0
we can put it as a 0 vector where
our x vector this general x vector
what is it this is our
er vector so this is the unit vector
along the radial direction
plus z e z vector
which means that what was previously x
vector minus psi vector magnitude
that is simply the magnitude
of our er vector plus z
is it vector
which is nothing but r square plus
z square square root so see things are
shaping up
shaping up to to more familiar forms
so with this understanding or with this
change of viewpoint
how can we possibly uh simplify this
expression
okay so let me copy this let me try to
copy this
[Music]
um
so this is my twice gu
vector so this becomes now
minus gradient of
so this is simply this x vector minus
i vector as i've written here this is r
e
r vector plus said e z vector
[Music]
dotted with what is my p vector
so p vector you note from my figure 2
so in this figure 2 this is this is
this is p vector now
with reference to this cylindrical
coordinate system this p
vector is simply here it is p vector
is equal to p e z
vector because it is oriented along the
z direction so that's what we are going
to use here
[Music]
p e z vector this will considerably
simplify
our algebra
so this 8 pi into 1 minus new factor
remains as it is
and as you have just seen this magnitude
it becomes square root of r square
plus z square and here we can have
p e z vector
[Music]
and this denominator becomes twice pi
into square root of r square plus
z square okay so
we can make a little bit of the
simplification here by noting
uh by by actually carrying out this dot
product you note
that er vector or this er unit vector
it is perpendicular to this ez vector
is it is it a unit hat so
the dot product of that is 0 so what we
end up with
is this thing
t z from a multiplication between these
two and e z
dotted with e z is one so
[Music]
now you see what is happening here
what we can do is we can uh for
for for clearer understanding of what is
going on and perhaps to simplify these
expressions also
we can uh decompose or we can consider
the the the different components
which are present here so the component
along the r direction and the component
along the z direction separately here
so you understand that this u vector
here
that is also in this fashion
so it is twice g
u r e r hat plus
u z e z hat
so we just have to equate the
coefficients of the er hat and the z
hat but before that we have to note that
this thing
this gradient uh
that is uh
er hat del del r
plus e z hat del del z
this entire thing operating on whatever
was present inside the curly brackets
[Music]
so uh what we have
is twice g u r
will be equal to just the coefficient of
the the the er
on the right hand side and that's going
to be
uh minus
del del r of this entire thing
pz 8 pi
divided by 8 by 1 minus nu r square
plus z square
and we don't have any other term here
so let me get my page all right uh
okay so uh and separately the
the user will have uh so let me just
write it here
the u z will be
minus del del z
of this
pz divided by 8
pi into 1 minus nu r square plus z
square
plus this entire term plus p
divided by twice pi
r square plus z square
sorry about the clutter here uh
okay so what i'm interested in doing
here is to proceed with this
ur component okay so so
so just to to get a fair idea of
of the the kind of expressions we'll be
dealing with
uh you see for the purpose of this
partial differentiation with respect to
r
this z here is basically a constant so
it might as well come out
just like this p this 8 pi 1 minus u can
come out
so that's that's nice here so
of course using something like uh
symbolic python in jupiter notebook
uh you can carry out these expressions
you can carry out the
the i mean you can find out the answers
to these expressions in half a second
uh anyway well we'll just do it for
manually here
[Music]
okay so the result of this
will be uh
so this is like us r square plus z
square to the power minus half
up so
we are going to get a minus half out of
this
[Music]
and uh this r squared plus
s squared this is minus half
minus one so using the simple
differentiation
rules and ultimately we have to
differentiate this with respect to
r so this is twice r
[Music]
and this twice will cancel with this
this two will cancel with this two and
uh you note here this is just a minus
three by two
so up and this minus and this minus
becomes a plus so
ultimately what we'll end up with is
this pz
divided by 8 pi into 1 minus nu
and then this r square plus z square
to the power 3 by 2. uh
[Music]
oh sorry this uh r is missing so i i
must put this r here so this is p
z r divided by eight pi into one minus
nu square root of
oh sorry r square plus z square to the
power three by two
ah this use it will have to do a little
bit more hard work
because you see this uh the z is present
here in the numerator
and the partial differentiation here is
with respect to
z uh now
[Music]
you have to note something very
important here okay so we have we have
bypassed the discussion
uh regarding the the boundary conditions
uh at the very outset so if you go back
to our figures
if we go back to our figures here
you should note uh the kind of boundary
conditions which will be
present here so
referring to this more general figure
you see we really don't have a
a real physical boundary present here
and again and again i emphasize that
this white curve that i have drawn here
it is only for the purpose of
visualization that there is some
material here
okay but this this this boundary is not
really present is present at infinity
okay so uh in these kinds of situations
uh we have to impose a very special kind
of i should not say impulse we we have
the physical situation demands it that
that
that we utilize a very special kind
of a boundary condition where of course
the term boundary condition is uh
is very much within air quotes uh
meaning to say that yeah it's it's more
like a far
field condition so what we say is that
uh
at x vector
uh tending to infinity
okay the u vector
is going to be equal to 0 please note
that i am specifying my boundary
condition or whatever this far field
condition is
in terms of the displacement vector i am
not actually
writing this in terms of the b vector of
the beta vector because those are some
things which are part of just the pop
coefficient of a representation which
helps means to
just to proceed with the solution
ultimately this
the problem that i'm solving for is to
find out the the displacement
vector so whatever conditions are
imposed must be
uh utilizing those things okay so
uh so in the in these terms uh
what do you think would be the situation
here
so try to think of it like this so so
maybe if you proceed along this line
okay so as r tends to infinity okay so
as r tends to infinity
of the you would have uh such a
situation
that uh the components of the
displacement
vector they turn to what they tend to
zero
okay uh so
so can we perhaps think along those
lines
and try to see what is going on here in
the in the solution
uh this this one component of the
solution that we have
obtained of what is going on here so
suppose you think of r tending to
infinity
okay so what we can do is
we can
we can consider this qr and write the
expression
in a slightly different fashion
[Music]
so we take this down below here
and
[Music]
now what i want to do is
[Music]
uh so let me just
[Music]
think so what i wanted to do was place
this r here
um
okay so i'll leave the r
here what i really want is
to have an r square within this bracket
so that means i have to put our
our cube here
so that i end with
so
all right so i'll have
a 1 by r square here
[Music]
and i'll have a r
squared plus z square
divided by r square here
[Music]
all right
[Music]
which means
so this is z this is 1 by r square
[Music]
okay so this is the form that i am
interested in
so now if i take the limit that r
tends to infinity then my twice g
u r that becomes
equal to zero because you see r tends to
infinity here
so uh so this this numerator it tends to
zero
and this denominator this term it tends
to one because this tends to zero this
is one plus zero so
so this this this thing tends to one
this is just a constant factor so this
entire thing becomes
tends to zero uh
and you can you can just see that if if
you're sitting on the line
z equal to uh on the on the longitudinal
axis and z is equal to zero so of course
no matter how how uh it doesn't really
matter how how
uh far away from the point
uh of application of the body force you
are uh the ur of course is going to be
zero on that line
so it gives us a fair idea that
this solution this solution that we have
obtained for this at least for this ur
and you will see a similar sort of thing
happens with the uz so
remember this u r we obtained
from uh from this general form
and this general form in turn was
obtained
general form was obtained in turn
by accepting the missing link that
we were not considering any uh
homogeneous part
solution for this b vector and the beta
but what is turning out is this so
what is turning out is something very
nice
okay and this is the part where i
discuss something
in relation to our missing link but
don't really
go on with a proof so what we are saying
is that
this solution
ah for u r
comes from
the u uh considering figure 2
[Music]
considering figure 2 and
this in turn
comes from
[Music]
the u the u vector
of figure one
[Music]
and that u vector
was obtained
just from the particular solutions
just from the particular solutions
[Music]
be vectored and so
b vector p and beta p
so really what we are what we have been
considering all along
uh
we have been considering this very
strictly speaking what we have been
considering
or working with is
[Music]
the up vector okay but
you see what is it what is this
thing solving this up vector is
actually solving the original navier
laming equations
considering the body force and
it turns out the the solution for this
for for this thing is such that it is
solving or it is satisfying the overall
boundary conditions for the displacement
vector
so this is a very very subtle point okay
so this u uh this
u vector p is certainly solving
the original navial lambda equations
uh sorry about the pattern writing here
satisfying the original navial lamin
equations
uh very importantly
the naviolamine equations which include
the body force
of course for this kelvins problem this
body force
is nothing but the the p vector
the delta x vector minus psi vector
but whatever this form is it does
include the body force
so it certainly satisfies that those
nagiolami equations
and it turns out
that this solution
satisfies
the far field
[Music]
the far field conditions
[Music]
for the original u
it satisfies the far field conditions
for the original u
okay so this original u was supposed to
satisfy the navier lambie equations and
it was supposed to satisfy this
far field uh conditions and it turns out
that the particular solution that we are
obtaining
that is also doing the same thing okay
so it's very very nice here
so again i'm repeating the original u
that we that we desired to find out that
was supposed to satisfy the navier
lamins equations
including the body forces that is
certainly being solved
that is certainly being satisfied by the
particular solution itself
the extra condition that we wanted for
the original u to satisfy
was the far field boundary condition
which was that you must tend to zero as
as we go away and away far away from the
point of application of the body force
and that condition that far-field
condition is very much satisfied by the
particular solution itself
as we have just seen here so at least
at least from this from this
illustrative case of this
you are we are seeing that uh far away
from the point of application
of the of the body force it is indeed
turning to zero
so it is it is as if
it is as if this particular solution is
not just a particular solution
it is the solution okay which is why
which is why
back here uh if i can just go back a
little bit
back here this missing link okay
so how so this question that we had
posed how the particular solution
becomes the total solution
that that is where the explanation of
the missing link is
okay this particular solution becomes
the total solution
because it just so happens that this
particular solution certainly satisfies
the original governing equation
as well as it satisfies the far-field
condition so we don't have to
worry about the homogeneous part at all
okay
so with this explanation uh
the the solution on the solution part
for the kelvins problem as far as the
displacements is concerned
is done now uh what we can go on to do
is uh is from these displacement
fields from from the answers of these
displacement fields we can find out the
strains
and from those strains we can find out
the stresses
and once you find out the stresses you
can you can do some verifications okay
uh and those are the kind of
verifications which have been
uh which have been carried out uh in in
our
textbook example
uh so so we can we can do those
things very easily now all right on that
note i will end this lecture thank you
very much